You know,
I,
uh,
when I was at the paper,
I would let my assistant,
Arthur Bovino very good journalists,
uh,
he and I would,
we had a game,
we would both read the paper before we
came to work and we would bet on what
was the mail going to be about,
what were people going to be complaining
about.
And of course,
within a couple of months we knew
exactly what people would be complaining
about.
We learned how the average times reader
or not even the average time sort of the
times readers in general responded to
the newspaper.
So I began to respond that way and I
would see things that would irritate me
that I might not have noticed at an
earlier time.
I tried to stop doing that when I left
the paper.
And I've been pretty good about it.
The only time that I really wanted to go
and grab somebody around the neck was
the Duke Lacrosse case.
And I'm happy to save it.
I'm proud to say I gave a speech to the
journalists,
journalism fellows at Harvard,
um,
while that was breaking barriers within
the first month.
And I said,
this is going to be a catastrophe.
This journalism is not good journalism
and this is something where a story is
being blown up to much larger scale than
it deserves to be because it fits so
many preconceptions of so many of the
editors at the Times.
Uh,
you know,
it was white over black,
it was rich over pour,
it was educated over an educated,
it was male over female.
Aha,
let's go do something about this.
And uh,
because the times did it,
that led to everybody else doing it.
So Newsweek does a cover story that
never would've happened had not,
the times has been putting it on the
front page for several days.
So that was driving me crazy.
On the other hand,
it wasn't my job any longer to be the
cop.
So I left that to my successor.
Well,
the biggest problems confronting the
time,
specifically we at the same problems as
providing it,
confronting everybody in the news
business,
which is that people don't seem to be
willing to pay for their news or let me
turn that around.
I think the times it seems very
reluctant to charge people for the news,
although they have announced that
they're going to begin charging,
uh,
online,
um,
in early 2011.
Uh,
I still sense of trepidation and I wish
it were otherwise.
I wish they had more confidence.
I think that it may be hard for this
regional paper,
that metropolitan paper or the small
town paper to charge for news,
but I think the times can get away with
it because it is the,
for a large portion of the educated
populace,
it is the authoritative voice on what's
happening in the world.
Um,
you know,
there are something like,
I don't know how many tens of,
I think it's now over 10 million people.
Let me restate that.
You know,
there are millions of people who go to
that website every day,
all over the world.
Now if you started charging $10 a month,
would a lot of them stop?
Yes.
Would all of them stop note would 50%
stop?
I don't know.
But I did the math not long ago and I
think that if 20% of them stayed,
that would cover the cost of the
newsroom and what the people in the news
business seem reluctant to realize is
that's the only thing that matters,
that that it's the production of news
being rewarded with revenue to cover the
costs and perhaps produce a profit.
That's what counts.
The making of a newspaper isn't what
counts.
And I think you know,
if,
if somebody had gone to the newspaper
Publishers and magazine Publishers of
America 20 years ago and said,
I have a new business model for you.
No paper,
no ink,
no trucks,
no teamsters,
no pressman,
no printer's Union,
no newsstands.
They'd say,
give it to me tomorrow.
This is heaven.
We just want to put our words and
pictures out there.
But they were so intent on protecting
the current revenue stream.
The money that advertisers pay and the
money that individuals pay for the
paper,
that they didn't see that this was a
boon for them and they made the same
mistake that the music business made in
the music business,
lost control of their industry.
They lost control of it,
the Steve Jobs,
because they want it to continue to sell
cds for $15 each.
And I think that the same thing's
happening in the print business.
I'm glad to see that the times is
moving,
and I think once the times moves,
many other institutions will move as
well.
Charge people for your product if
they're not willing to pay for it,
maybe you've got a problem with your
product.
Yeah.